danger le ver dois être honnête oui
c'est de la daube france en haïti s'est
avéré nettement et vous déçoit non mais
vous vous dites sont énormes et encore
plus encore pire la tête de ma mère il a
fait impossible après un jeudi à la gare
et le gars mais c'est pas c'est pas
possible vos phares qui l'a envoyé mon
père il envoyait un taux je crois que
c'est une boule de bowling shrek stack
avait commencé bien c'est un truc de fou
et si c'est pour faire ça
effectivement on le connaît pour pour
des émissions comme ça où il ya des
conflits donc ne pas sortir de sa zone
de confort c'est pratique mais moi je
préfère par exemple comme fort boyard
une émission bienveillante donc les
émissions feelgood c'est chouette
hélas quand il ya des gens qui se
chamaillent fin moi perso je l'aimé pas
des choses ont tourné en compagnie de
shermag que oui à la vie n'est pas
forcément feel good
emma je pense que c'est tout à la vie
c'est alors je l'aï parfois non mais
alors je vous dis ah ouais je vous le
dis je suis d'accord et vous c'est pas
un long fleuve tranquille c'est pas ya
l'eau qui coule de source
absolument oui alors je pense que c'est
l'homme de la situation c'est le
chevalier blanc de rtl sur m6 et pascal
acbr gilles choix qu'a toujours à
longueur de journée le peuple les gens
mais y'a des gens qui ont des procédures
qui seront pas très très cher qui sont
très onéreuses avec des avocats qui
coûte une fortune
et justement il peut peut-être aider
certaines personnes à trouver des
situations et les solutions pour des
conflits oui alors si vous pouvez éviter
de faire appeler comme ça et de faire
comme ça je le prends mal aux chouchous
c'est un excellent format avec cessé ces
deux restrictions c'est qu'aux états
unis est là le juge judy à une vraie
autorité parce qu'il était pendant 30
ans juge dans un tribunal aux états unis
voilà julien courbet et surtout aux
états unis il s'engage à respecter la
décision de l'émission à bout ça lui
donne un vrai intérêt l'émission quand
même et la première émission je vous le
dis j'ai une info vraiment qui vient de
tomber je vous dire ce sera le divorce
de benjamin castaldi